Yeah,
it's great to
be back in October last year and then
made,
I've now made two documentaries about
you and a big focus for rebel.
Wisdom is kind of making sense of the
cultural moment and making sense of your
success and what it represents and I
don't know if you remember the very
first question I asked you back in
October in the interview was firstly
what do you make of your success so far
and are you ready for it to continue?
Because I had.
I had a sense back then,
but what your message represented with
something in the culture desperately
needed this sort of what that signifies
to me as a kind of reintegration of the
sacred.
Did you have any sense back then the,
the exponential success that you were
going to have between then and now?
Well,
I mean the most likely outcome at each
of the what?
What would you say at each point where I
might notice what's going on around me
has been that this was stopped but it
isn't stopping,
so I've been thinking about that pretty
much nonstop I would say,
and I have some,
some solutions.
Let's say,
or some ideas that I didn't present in
October,
so one of the things I've realized is
that part of what's pushing
part of what's accounting for this,
the popularity of my ideas is actually a
secondary consequence of a technological
revolution.
And I've seen that more clearly since
October,
um,
partly because I can see the mainstream
media dying at a faster and faster rate
and the alternative media expanding
faster and faster.
So television radio and the classic
print media had shared one thing in
common which was a extreme restriction
in bandwidth.
This was especially true of television
because each minute of television,
given the,
the necessity to broadcast and the
expensive,
that was unbelievably expensive.
And so there just wasn't time to do
anything on television.
There's no time.
And so if you had something important to
say,
um,
or even something unimportant for that
matter,
most of the time it had to be compressed
into something approximating 30 seconds,
which wouldn't even be your words.
That would be a journalist.
Common commenting on what you said and
if you were really pushing the envelope,
maybe you'd have 25 minutes on a talk
show that was devoted to your ideas,
but then even that would be highly
scripted and so television made people
look stupider than they were even to the
producers of television because of this
narrow.
The the rise of video online and audio
as well has blown the bandwidth
limitation out of our mass communication
and it turns out that people are smarter
with longer attention spans.
Then we thought what happened with me
was that for one reason or another I was
an early adopter of that technology and
so there's this massive technological
transformation which is a Gutenberg
revolution in the provision of video and
audio.
No barrier to production because it
doesn't cost anything.
Anyone can do it.
People can communicate with it.
You can cut up youtube videos,
you can make your documentaries.
The entry point is easy.
Audio podcasts and that sort of thing,
which can be of indefinite length,
allow people to use,
found time to listen.
More people can listen.
Then can read like all of these things
add up to a massive technological
revolution and it's that upswell in
technology that's in part has propelled
what I've been doing to,
to,
to the,
to this mass audience.
And so that's been a relief to figure
that out because it depersonalizes it to
some degree.
Right.
And so I use the metaphor,
we're not been asked about this before
of being on a wave surfing on a giant
wave,
but the wave isn't something that I've
done.
It's part of this technological
revolution.
So that's a relief to know that and I'm
quite convinced that that's the case
because there are other people who are
occupying the same space.
Essentially.
Joe Rogan is a very good example of that
and the various commentators on,
on Youtube who've,
who've become increasingly influential
and powerful.
Same thing driven by the technology.
They happen to be early adopters and so.
And then there's a secondary question
which is,
well,
is there anything specific in
relationship to my content,
let's say?
And I would say also that isn't the case
and I think what I've been able to do
with reasonable effectiveness is to draw
a conceptual,
a equation equivalence between the
meaning that's necessary to sustain you
in life,
given it's suffering and malevolence and
the necessity to dog responsibility.
And I think there's something new about
that.
I mean,
I don't know how new.
I'm sure I'm not the first person who's
discovered that,
but I think I've done a reasonable job
of pointing out to people that,
that the suffering that's intrinsic to
life in the absence of meaning is not
tolerable.
It,
it,
it destroys and corrupts and that the
proper pathway out of isn't rights or
happiness or entitlement or,
or anything that's associated with,
with,
with individual ease,
let's say.
But with the adoption of something
approximating maximal responsibility.
And people get that,
like it's,
it's not that hard to understand when
it's laid out like that.
And lots of people,
especially young people,
especially people who are young and also
somewhat nihilistic in their
orientation,
uh,
perhaps because of an excess of
intellectual criticism are they grabbed
that immediately.
I think,
oh,
there's the missing piece.
I see.
It's that the antidote to this
meaninglessness,
this void that I'm confronting isn't
hedonism.
It's not right.
It's not impulsive pleasure.
It's none of that.
It's responsibility.
It's like,
Oh yes,
okay.
That everything snaps into place.
And so that's been.
I think that's the most essential part
of the message to the degree that what
I'm doing has an essential message.
That would be it.
And I do think that's what accounts for
a large part of its impact.
And you mentioned Joe Rogan before you
and he are grouped together in this sort
of new constellation of the intellectual
dark web.
What do you see as the,
I mean,
what do you make of your kind of
inclusion in this and what do you see as
its role going forward in the cultural
organization?
Yeah,
well it's,
it's,
it's like a herd of cats,
right?
Because so I've thought about,
well,
what,
what unites us to the degree that
there's an us,
because that's not so self evident.
There's enough of us so that the name he
and it stuck.
So,
so there's something in common because
otherwise the name wouldn't have stuck,
right?
You can't name nothing.
It doesn't work.
And I've talked to a fair bit about this
with Dave Rubin because Dave Rubin and I
have been touring together,
right?
He opens my mind discussions and adds a
nice comedic touch to them.
And um,
so what do we have in common?
Everybody in the group is an independent
practitioner.
So an entrepreneur essentially with
their own media enterprise that's
autonomous.
None of us are serving any master except
the audience.
So,
so,
and,
and we're all somewhat independent
financially as a consequence of that.
And so that makes us beholden to no
master.
All of us are engaged in these long form
discussions,
right?
And one of the consequences of being
engaged in long form discussion is that
you can assume that your intelligence,
that your audience is intelligent.
And so that's another thing that unites
everybody in the group is we all assume
that our audience is intelligent,
but I think that that's not so much a
consequence of any particular moral
virtue on our parts,
but an observation that the technology
has made possible.
It's like,
oh,
and you can see this,
I would say particularly with Rogan
because in some sense he's a trailblazer
in this domain.
It's like,
oh,
turns out my audience will listen to a
three hour discussion.
But he wouldn't have been able to
discover that without the technology.
Right?
So now to his credit,
he was smart enough to discover it and
smart enough to notice it when he
discovered it.
And so,
and I,
I think that also characterize as the
rest of the people in this group,
it's like,
oh,
look at that,
the audience actually wants our
listeners,
let's say,
and viewers want detailed in depth,
unscripted,
spontaneous,
meaningful conversation and then really
are willing to go in that direction.
That's the risk taking element.
Like,
well,
I can give you an example of that.
So,
um,
I just did four talks with Sam Harris,
who's often grouped into this group as
well.
I'm on the relationship between science
and religion,
say,
or facts and values.
That's another way of thinking about it
with a bit of politics thrown in a
discussion of left rate differences and
so on.
Um,
what's the willingness to take the risk?
Well,
I have no idea.
When I met Sam in Vancouver,
which was where the first two of the
four talks were held.
I never met him before.
We did a podcast together,
one of which was very.
We got locked in the other one,
which was more productive I would say,
but I had no idea if he had,
I could talk,
but we,
we,
we were willing to willing to.
I guess that's right.
Agreed to take the risk to see if we
could talk in a public forum.
And I think that's another thing that
characterizes the people in that group
is that they will take those sorts of
risks.
If you go into a television studio,
a classic television studio,
all the conversation is scripted and
it's actually quite frustrated because
you can't have a conversation with the
journalist because the journalist isn't
there,
who's there is a frontest piece for the
organization and the organization has
scripted all their responses and so it's
not actually like talking to a person.
It's really like talking to a puppet.
So for better or for worse,
but in these low unscripted loan form
conversations,
then you can take the risk of having a
conversation and that can go
spectacularly well,
but it can also fail dismally.
So I would say those are the things that
united us to the degree that the group
exists.
I mean I've met who I was in la a week
ago and about seven of us got together
for,
for dinner
and that was the first time we met as
anything approximating a group.
And you know,
it was interesting to watch everybody
interact because as I said,
it really is a herd of cats.
There's tremendous diversity of
political opinion and a tremendous
diversity of personality.
Like Eric Weinstein and Joe Rogan.
Like they're not even members of the
same species in some ways,
you know,
so,
so it,
it's a very fractious group,
but I think those things that I outlined
are the elements that basically united,
there's also something that I sent to
watching some of the discussions.
There's a kind of intellectual curiosity
and a sense of people thinking in public
and there's also a sense of maybe the
potential for people to change their
minds or to,
to,
to discover things during the course.
Was that partly the appreciation of the
intelligence of the audience?
It's like,
and I would say it is actually the
manifestation of the process of thinking
that's more important than the
conclusions that are generated even in
these discussions that I've been having
with Harris.
Like we are trying to,
to argue out to different viewpoints
because Harris believes that values can
be derived with,
with,
with unerring precision in some sense
using the proper methodology from facts.
And I,
I believe that it's more complicated
than that,
that there has to be intermediate
structures and those are really
narrative and in their nature.
So there's a technical argument,
um,
as well as a variety of sub arguments
about the relative role of traditional
religion and so forth,
but the outcome of the debate about
those issues is partly what people are
coming to the talks to see,
to determine what should the conclusions
be,
but a much larger part perhaps is to
observe and engage at least by proxy in
the process of dialogue.
And that's more important because
dialogue is the process by which complex
problems are solved.
Which is what makes me a free speech
advocate fundamentally was not an
advocate.
It's like I realized that that,
that protection for free speech is
protection of the mechanism whereby
complex social problems are solved and
we're,
we're the people in this group and many
other people as well are acting out that
dialogical process and,
and,
and people are happy about that as they
should be.
And I've read the spectator review of
your recent conversation.
I think you've now come to the end of
your debates with Sam Harris and they
said that you expressed a little bit of
irritation at some of the stuff when Sam
didn't grasp.
Some of the points that you're making or
that you didn't fully appreciate that he
read and understood them.
I also think that Sam Harris in
particular,
like he's built a whole kind of
personality career,
several books on this atheism position.
Do you think that he can argue in good
faith from that perspective?
Could he turn round and say,
well actually,
no,
you're right.
This atheism
thing is a bit simplistic.
He was,
I think he was,
I think he was conducting the discussion
in good faith.
I actually think that what Sam is doing
is a good faith project.
You know,
he,
I think there's conceptual muddiness
about it.
Um,
but you know,
he,
his basic premise is that we could come
to an agreement that working to reduce
unnecessary misery and suffering is a
universal good slim.
Okay,
fair enough.
That seems like a reasonable
proposition.
I don't think it's a proposition of
fact.
And he claims that it is,
but that doesn't matter still.
It's fair enough,
man.
And then,
you know,
so that's one proposition.
The other proposition is it would be
really good if our systems of value
weren't founded on air.
And what do we have that's not air?
What we have facts,
we have objective facts.
I mean,
look at the technology,
look at what we've done with our
science.
It's like you don't want to
underestimate the utility of objective
facts,
so maybe we can ground the value
structure in the facts.
It's like,
well,
that would be good if we could do it so
and,
and so.
And then his,
his ethic,
let's say,
as an amalgam of those two propositions.
And I think that his project is
honorable and,
and I think he's committed to it.
He also rightly is concerned with the
dangers of the fundamentalist dangers of
revealed truth.
Um,
and so it's very skeptical about,
about the axiomatic claims of,
of dogmatic religion.
It's like,
yeah,
fair enough.
But
his,
the mechanisms that he outlines to
derive values from facts are
insufficient in my estimation.
I don't think that his argument is
sufficiently sophisticated,
even though I don't doubt it's,
I don't think that Sam is any less
committed to an ethical good.
It's not obvious to me that he is than I
am,
you know,
and he's argued and discussed
fully in good faith as far as I'm
concerned,
you know,
with the,
with the odd error because no one is
negotiating 100 percent all the time in
good faith.
I mean that's a standard that no one
can,
can achieve,
but I think the discussions have been
unbelievably productive and,
and we'll see that certainly the crowds
are respond.
I don't think the crowds would have been
engaged if Sam wouldn't have been,
wouldn't have been discussing in good
faith,
you know,
because the engagement is actually an
indication that a good faith discussion
is,
is occurring.
Otherwise it gets dealt very,
very rapidly.
We'll see what happens when the videos
are released and that'll be in August.
Once their sound is edited and all of
that,
and then people will have a public
debate about how it,
how did discussion proceeded.
I also think that each discussion built
on the previous one and that we both
ended up.
I think we both ended up more informed
and more articulate than we started out.
So that's a good.
That's a really good thing.
I certainly understand his argument is
much better than I did well a year ago,
let's say,
and I've heard Eric Weinstein described
sort of the cultural moment is a kind of
civil war within the left,
sort of extreme left and then sort of
moderate soft left,
um,
which,
uh,
probably sort of the,
at least the dominating kind of paradigm
in the media.
Um,
I,
I'm,
I've got a lot of progressive friends
and what I see happening recently maybe
in the last couple of weeks is a lot of
them starting to grapple with your
ideas.
Um,
and looking at asking this question,
what can the left learn from Jordan
Peterson,
um,
which is,
which is a pretty new development
because I saw a lot of kind of
reactivity to it before.
How can you personally contribute to
that debate?
And
is that a debate you're interested in
contributing?
Absolutely.
No,
no doubt about it,
no doubt about it.
Um,
one thing that I've been doing in my
tour repeatedly when I talk about the
first chapter of my book,
which is stand up straight with your
shoulders back,
it's a discussion of hierarchies and
their eternal nature,
right?
Because my claim,
not my claim,
I think it's mirror fact that organisms
that have to cooperate and compete with
other organisms have their type
inevitably arrange themselves into
hierarchies.
And that's been going on for so long,
which is at least 300 million years that
our nervous systems have adapted to
hierarchies as if they're a permanent
element of being right,
more permanent than treats like
seriously permanent at the most
fundamental neurochemical,
the one that regulates the entire brain.
Serotonin is acutely sensitive to
hierarchical distinctions.
And so that's part of the proposition.
So the reason I laid that proposition
forward was to say whatever pitfalls
hierarchies might produce,
you cannot lay them at the feet of the
West Patriarchy or capitalism.
It's like that's a nonstarter.
You're wrong and not just a little bit
wrong.
You're so seriously wrong that if you
insist upon doing that,
you won't even achieve your own names
because you're actually not grappling
with the problem.
The problem is if hierarchies are a
problem,
which they are,
the problem is way more serious than
mere capitalism.
It's way deeper and if you're actually
interested in rectifying the cons,
the negative consequences of
hierarchies,
then you're going to have to get a lot
more sophisticated than your,
than your idiot Marxism.
So,
so,
so part of the elaboration of that
argument is,
well,
hierarchies are inevitable because we
have to solve complex problems and we
have to solve them socially.
And when you implement a solution to a
complex problem,
socially you produce a hierarchy because
some people are better at the
implementation than others.
So there's a hierarchy of competence and
then there's a hierarchy of distribution
of the spoils.
And so,
and in both of those hierarchies,
you get a disproportionate clumping of
resources at the top and disposition at
the bottom and the nature of
hierarchies.
So what's the left for?
The left is to remind those who are
benefiting from the hierarchies that the
hierarchy comes at a cost and the cost
is the clumping of people at the bottom
and that that's an internal costs and
it's not trivial,
and so that's what the left should be
properly focused on.
The left should be providing the voice
of those who are dispossessed by
hierarchies and the right should be
saying,
yeah,
but the damn hierarchies are necessary
and they're not only necessary,
but they're also productive.
Then the left says yes,
but they tilt towards tyranny and they
can be occupied inappropriately by
people who are playing games of power.
Fair enough.
The right has to take that into account.
The hierarchy can rigidity,
rigidified,
and is likely to do that and it can be
taken over by people who are corrupt and
that's likely to happen.
And so,
but,
but it's okay because the dialogue could
work out.
The right can say,
well yeah,
we need the damn hierarchies and they
need to be about trust.
And the left can say yes,
but they have to be maintained properly
so they don't deteriorate and
degenerate.
And I think that's,
I think that's ancient wisdom.
I think the ancient Egyptians had
figured that out in their symbolic
representations.
So now when the left goes too far,
it does something like say,
well,
how about no hierarchies?
It's like,
no,
how about not wrong?
Because all that happens if you flat.
One of the things that happens if you
flatten out the hierarchy is that you
can't even organize your perceptions.
You can't perceive the world without
looking at the world through a hierarchy
of value.
And if because you can't perceive the
world unless you make one thing more
important than all the other things
because you don't even know what to look
at,
and if one thing isn't more important
than all the other things,
then you have nothing to aim at.
If you have nothing to aim at and you
have no meaning in your life,
so the left can't just demolish the
hierarchies in the name of some equality
of outcome,
let's say,
because you blow out the future,
you leave people aimless,
and you destroyed the very institutions
that allow people to make competent
progress in the world.
That's not an acceptable outcome,
so we have to,
we have to agree to live with the
tension necessity for hierarchies that
proclivity for them to pathologize and
the necessary voice of the left and
speaking for the,
for the dispossessed.
So and I mean I've.
As far as I'm concerned,
I've said something approximating that
through my entire career.
So the fact that the left wingers have
been irritated at me as well,
in some sense that's an inevitable
consequence of me taking on the radical
left wingers,
but it's also the refusal by the
moderate left to deal with their
internal problems
and the sticking point that I hear a lot
from my sort of more progressive friends
is your sort of primary focus is on the
individual.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's too bad for them because their
primary focus should be on the
individual.
I can agree with that,
but what I.
The paradox,
they would say it's like,
okay,
focus on the individual,
but you have to accept that there are
some situations that are much more
conducive to an individual thriving and
other situations and so they're focused
on structural inequality.
Your focusing on the individual,
is there not some interplay?
Well,
obviously because people do have group
identities.
The question is whether whether the
group or the individual identity should
be paramount and the leftist dance.
The radical leftist answer is,
well,
there is the look,
it's not me that's failing to take into
account those two levels of analysis.
It's the bloody radical leftist because
for them it's the collective and that's
that and so it's obvious as far as I'm
concerned that people have their
individuality and then behind that they
have there.
They have their group,
multiple group identities which is also
a big problem
or any of these situations that make it
much more difficult for people to self
actualize.
What what I think they'd argue with.
They don't hear you talk about that very
much.
Well,
it isn't.
First of all,
it's not self evident like I'm not.
I don't accept maslow's hierarchy of
needs.
I don't think it's necessarily more
difficult for people who are poor to
self actualize.
Sorry,
I don't buy that because what that would
mean.
Think about what that would mean.
That would mean that the rich are
morally superior.
That's what that means,
because they have all the opportunities
to self actualize.
So obviously if the material conditions
are the prerequisite for self
actualization,
then the rich are morally superior to
the poor.
Is that really an argument we want to
make?
And then in fact,
I don't think that that's even even
vaguely reasonable because one of the
things that does help build character is
privation.
Now obviously starving to death is an,
an excess of privation.
So there are limit conditions,
but
the,
it's a leftist trope that the provision
of additional material resources will
produce ethically superior human beings.
Sorry,
not true.
And in fact,
sometimes quite the contrary.
So,
so,
um,
so I don't,
I don't,
I don't buy that argument in the least.
Um,
I also think that under most
circumstances,
it accepting those of exceptional
privation and even perhaps under those
conditions in most,
in most cases,
your best bet to move people forward is
to concentrate on the development of
their individual character and their
individual,
their individual moral character.
And because moral character is actually
your moral character is actually the set
of tools that you have to operate
effectively in the work because
otherwise morality would be of no
utility.
And morality is in some sense precisely
that w which is of maximal utility.
And so and,
and the other objection that I would
throw it at the radical leftists.
Well,
how do you know that your,
oh,
your emphasis on collective existence
isn't just an abdication of your
personal responsibility.
Well,
of course it's not.
It's like,
no,
no.
Seriously,
here,
it's not that easy to adopt personal
responsibility,
maximal personal responsibility.
What makes you think you're not running
away from it?
You have every reason to.
You really have that stellar moral
character.
Really,
that's,
that's yourself analysis.
Sorry,
I don't buy it.
And I especially don't buy it when I
look at the consequences of leftist
revolution because all of these people
have stellar moral character when they
undertake their collectivist revolution.
Nothing comes out of that,
but absolute bloody catastrophe.
So,
so all the well meaning aims aside,
my,
my sense of a lot of the progressive
people that I know is that they're not,
that they're sort of from a new
generation,
they're not generally materialists,
that they're sort of very spiritually
aware and I sense a kind of implicit
message in what you're saying.
I've never heard,
made explicitly that in some sense
materialism is a deadening doctrine.
I mean you look at the opiod crisis in
America,
you look at a lot of these.
If,
if poverty is seen as a more sort of
also also as a sort of spiritual crisis
or a crisis of the soul as much as
anything else.
Is it mostly.
That would be lovely if poverty was
caused by lack of money.
Hmm.
We could fix it really easily then.
But my point I think is to say that if,
if you frame your message in that way,
I think there will be a lot of people on
the left who would be receptive to that
message.
Sort of the that actually there is a
crisis of the crisis of,
what do you call it,
like worldview has real consequences and
a lot of poverty we're seeing in the
world is to do with this kind of
materialist worldview that has become,
become corrupt or at least kind of
stripped all of the meaning and purpose.
Yeah.
Well that,
that's a good point.
Well,
right.
I mean I don't believe that materialism,
materialist hedonism is a sufficient
solution.
Now it's bit more complicated than that
because I do think that functional
democratic systems are actually pretty
good at reasonable hedonism.
Like I'm pretty happy that our system
produces a variety of toothpastes and a
variety of toilet papers in a variety of
sanitary napkins.
All of these things that,
that are basically oriented towards,
what would you call them individually,
creature comforts.
There's something about that that's
really merciful and properly
egalitarian.
And so a certain degree of material
hedonism is a good thing,
right?
Because it,
it's nice that people can have their
basic needs taken care of in a dignified
manner.
Um,
but as,
as a ultimate solution to the problems
of life.
It's insufficient,
which is again why I don't really like
Abraham maslow's hierarchy of,
of,
of needs.
Now it isn't.
It isn't a progression up the moral
chain because of the provision of
additional material resources.
It doesn't work that way.
That doesn't mean that you don't want
to.
You want to set up a situation where as
many people as possible are absent the
terrible strictures of of privation,
but we are doing that quite rapidly.
Thank God so,
so I think we're.
The leftists are less happy with what
I'm doing is the case that I'm making
that the meaning that transcends mere
materialism is to be found in the
adoption of individual responsibility
because I wouldn't say that that's a
core message.
Certainly none of the radical left it.
It's not that at all because generally
they construe the individual as either
the oppressor or the suffering or
pressed but not as the active agent as
either of those active agents.
The problem with the oppressor of press
narrative is even though there's an
element of truth to it,
each of us can be subdivided into so
many group identities that there's at
least one dimension along which we're
all oppresses and that's actually when
I've been looking at what happened in
the aftermath of the Russian revolution.
That that was the bloody error,
so to speak.
Because you could take virtually every,
any individual and you could find out.
It's like if there's one dimension of
your identity that makes you an
oppressor,
that trumps all the elements of your
identity,
where you're a victim.
And the problem with that is there is
one element of your identity where
you're an oppressor and so that's
sufficient justification to throw you in
with the predators and do whatever is
necessary to dispense with you.
And that is exactly what happened in the
aftermath.
Will not only of the Russian revolution,
but all of these radical leftist
revolutions.
So like,
well,
if you're a socialist while you're not
sufficiently pure from a doctrinaire
perspective.
And if you're a student,
well then you're part of the emerging
bourgeois class.
And if your parents were reasonably,
what would you say?
Efficient farmers,
then you're part of the Kulaks and like
it just went on and on and on and on.
There wasn't anybody who escaped from
the,
from being tarred with the brush of
oppressor.
And that's because that is because each
of us are in fact oppressors and
oppressed.
Every single person shares both of those
things in common.
So,
um,
got a couple of minutes left.
So this might be quite a big question,
but just come back from the U.
s where we interviewed pool vander clay,
Christian pastor who's been doing quite
a lot of videos about your,
your thought he,
one of his questions was,
he says he,
he's,
he's a real sort of stoicism and your
thought for pick up your cross and drag
it up the hill.
His question is what's at the top of the
hill?
He doesn't hear that.
Well,
that's because he hasn't listened to the
times when I've been talking about it.
I guess because I've said it repeatedly.
You stumble up hill with your burden
towards the city of God.
That's the,
that's the store that does that.
I mean the city of gold
to you.
I would say that that's.
That's a place where everyone bears
maximum responsibility and speaks the
truth.
That's what it is.
And what's the responsibility?
You're responsible for the suffering in
the world.
You're responsible for the malevolence
in the world and you're responsible for
the veracity of your utterances.
Right?
And in the city of God,
you're maximally responsible for the
suffering.
You're maximally responsible for the
malevolence and you speak the truth.
That's what it is.
Very concise.
So you can tell them Paul van play that.
Great.
Jordan,
thank you very much.
My pleasure.
Nice to see you again.
You take.